the Black Clover movie just dropped on
Netflix a new chapter of the manga also
just dropped and the movie might have
actually spoiled the end of the manga
there are many connections between
what's happening in the manga right now
and what happened in the movie and the
truth about asta's ultimate power up may
have already been revealed so let's get
into it you guys know how this works if
you enjoy my Black Clover content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
helps me out a lot with that YouTube
algorithm and if you watch my videos but
you haven't subscribed yet do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is of course completely free
but it means a lot for the channel
finally this video will contain Black
Clover manga spoilers and some movie
spoilers as well so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the
previous chapters we see that many
members of the black Bulls led by
Vanessa travel to the witch's forest in
order to get the world's most Marvel
witches to help them create a long
distance magic portal that would allow
Asta to come back from Hino country
these witches including the witch Queen
and Dorothy unsworth set up an elaborate
ritual that will allow them to create
this portal through a super compound
magic spell centered around finral's
spatial magic and these guys really need
to hurry because things are not going so
well inside the Clover Kingdom capital
not only is Lucius using clones to
dominate the battle against his
opponents but the population of the
capital has finally come to the
realization that the main villain they
are fighting is none other than the man
they knew as Julius novacrono the wizard
King this realization obviously sent
everyone into panic mode because the man
they had trusted to protect them the
strongest Mage in the entire Kingdom
seemingly betrayed everyone and became a
villain Marx uses his communication
magic to essentially broadcast himself
to the entire capital and explain that
the wizard King know didn't betray them
instead his body has been possessed by a
villain that said this villain is an
insanely powerful enemy and yet despite
that so many Mages are risking their
lives in order to protect the kingdom
Marx and Mimosa then start talking up
yuno as the hero who can save them all
from Lucius the main goal of this speech
is to stop the people from panicking and
giving up by holding yuno up as the hope
of the Kingdom all is not lost yet and
you know is the Fearless Mage that
everyone can rally behind thanks to you
know spell all the citizens now possess
more power than normal so they must use
that power to save themselves and to
save others this speech is so powerful
that even dark lord Seka himself finally
decides to get involved and he then
proceeds to successfully protect some
fleeing citizens from an enemy attack
and I mean of course he's successful in
second the goat while else do you expect
seke then decides to finally get serious
which means that Lucius is basically
cooked I just hope second doesn't take
him out before Austin returns because I
do want to see full power Asta in action
before the battle ends and speaking of
our stuff he and the ryuzen 7 are ready
to be transported to the Clover Kingdom
but then there's a problem damn nishio
Kira has been turned into one of
lucius's paladins and he appears inside
the witch's Forest determined to stop
the teleportation Ritual from taking
place Lucius had anticipated that this
ritual would happen so he dispatched the
amnesio to the witch's Forest just to
make sure that the ritual fails Lucius
doesn't really care if Austin is dead or
alive the only thing he cares about is
keeping Asta away from the Clover
Kingdom Lucius may be overpowered but
he's clearly not cocky some villains
might want their most dangerous enemy to
face them so that they can test out
their full power on the enemy we've seen
that so many times in like Dragon Ball
but Lucius would rather play it safe and
keep asta's screwy anti-magic as far
away from him as possible a bunch of
forest witches then attack demacio
determined to prevent him from
interfering with the ritual but Amnesia
is able to easily erase their magic as a
paladin he has the power to ensure that
any magic used against him can be tilted
in his favor through the power of His
scale magic so the witches fail in their
attempt to stop him and he proceeds to
use the guardian angels to launch a
massive magic energy blast at the exact
location of the ritual however the black
Bulls are able to reverse Uno the energy
blast right back at demetio and his
angels as multiple members of the black
Bulls emerged to fight damnatio
including Vice Captain knocked luck
Magna Charmy gosh Zora sacrae and the
Black Bull base itself the latest
chapter comes to an end since finroll
Vanessa and the other witches were
important for the ritual haven't emerged
to fight damnatio it's safe to assume
that the ritual is still happening and
the black Bulls are fighting the amnesio
to hold him off long enough for the
ritual to be completed and for Asta to
emerge from the portal I mean yeah we
all know that Asta definitely will make
it back and take part in the final
battle eventually but Tabata decided
that he didn't want to make it too easy
for us he wanted to add some extra
attention to the ritual Itself by
throwing themnacio in the mix and
knowing the past between the nacio and
Asta I guess it's pretty fitting to have
them the issue attempt to keep Asta out
of the Clover Kingdom by any means
necessary looks like we're about to see
some epic black bull teamwork which is
something we haven't seen in a while and
I for one am here for it I mean yeah
damnatio is definitely gonna get bodied
and Asta is definitely about to come
back but I don't mind seeing the other
black balls in action before that
happens in the end it's going to be Asta
versus Lucius but Asta won't be alone
talberta didn't build yuno up so much
for nothing and there are many Mages
that are going to have an important role
to play in the final battle and this
brings me to the events of the Black
Clover movie which is called sword of
the wizard King I personally enjoyed it
quite a bit and I loved seeing some of
the former wizard Kings being introduced
into the story the most important
element in the movie is probably the
sword itself known as the Imperial sword
elsodokia this sword was created by the
first wizard King lemiel silvamillion
and it was passed down from Wizard King
to wizard King all the way up to the
27th wizard King julius's predecessor
Conrad Leto the crazy thing about this
sword is that it's able to absorb and
store magic power and once a whole bunch
of magic power is stored inside of it it
can be released with incredibly
destructive potential in fact this sword
is a weapon so powerful that it's said
to have the capacity to destroy an
entire country on top of that the sword
is also said to contain a piece of every
former wizard King's soul and Magic the
first wizard King created the sword as a
way to make sure that the wizard Kings
of the future would be able to use the
power of their predecessors to protect
the Clover Kingdom but of course Conrad
Leto had other ideas for the sword in
the climax of the movie Asta is able to
take hold of the sword and use its magic
together with his Demon's air sword and
anti-magic in order to defeat Conrad
this was an epic finish in which we saw
some of the Clover Kingdom's most
powerful Mages lending their own magic
to Asta so that Asta could use both
magic and anti-magic at the same time
which was really cool cool to see but
the more I think about it the more this
situation with Conrad lettle reminds me
of the situation with Lucius like Lucius
Conrad wanted to destroy the world as we
know it in order to create a new and
better world where people could live
happily and peacefully he believed that
a day of Destruction had to happen uh
Judgment Day if you will and then after
that those who are worthy AKA righteous
would be reborn into the world and
everything would be perfect and awesome
also like Lucius Conrad was able to
gather a whole bunch of different magic
attributes within himself and use them
all against his enemies and the amount
of magic he possessed was so
overwhelming that even anti-magic alone
couldn't cancel at all well Asta had to
use the most powerful weapon in the
Kingdom the sword of the wizard king and
the magic contained within it in order
to finish Conrad off anti-magic alone
was not enough I don't know about you
guys but this is basically how I was
expecting the final Arc in the manga to
end I expected Asta to play the main
role of course but I believe that his
anti-magic alone wouldn't be enough to
stop Lucius since Lucius possesses just
insane amounts of magic at this point I
expected this to be a team effort which
involves other powerful Mages lending
their magic to Asta Asta then combining
their magic with his anti-magic to
create some sort of black hole magic and
this black hole magic is then able to
consume and Destroy Lucius despite all
his immense magic power but now I feel
like this might be too similar to the
ending of the movie so is the manga
ending going to be different somehow or
did the movie Just spoil the ending of
the manga what did you guys think of the
movie will the main story end in a
similar way and if not then how do you
think that the black Culver manga will
end how will Lucius be defeated let me
know down below if you enjoyed this
black lore video want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
of course if you watch our black lower
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys